prof et mathieu de robot vous c'est vous
avez déjà travaillé ensemble vous avez
même faire défi l'un contre l'autre
bon appétit un défi ouais c'était on
avait fait de défier paul bret regardez
il va attention c'est parti
brad wall a bien commencé en plus ça va
tuer les premiers degrés de ouf
ces parcours [ __ ]
donc ça a l'air hyper lourd à aller
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ces matches et doit rester comme
ça deux heures
[Musique]
elway matthieu delormeau avait gagné le
premier opus et rohff un qui est un ami
m'a appelé et m'a dit j'aimerais le
défier au boxing mathieu contre europe
si si je peux pas vraiment s'y arrête le
jure que s'il pouvait mettre un coup
mais j'aime et c'est ridicule si le
taper à deux à l'heure vous pouvez
mettre un court of diamant la mouche
[Applaudissements]
mais france
il m'a dit c'est toi qui m'a demandé tu
m'a demandé j'ai fait ou pas mathieu tu
as gagné le premier round mais ça va
être ridicules ces affaires sont énormes
vas-y tu peux non je n'ai pas dit
mathieu si la queue à l'est
manu mais non ça va faire mal informés
notamment comme l'arrêt de la douleur
mais non thermale sûr que la salle c'est
ce que tu sais faire c'est ap
je suis vraiment non je suis prêt mais
de christian je me ferais pas mal et sa
série dit que je le fais radio alors ses
affaires sans nom rohff est ce que tu
peux voir des jacobins il va faire après
tu vas bien je veux le battre à 12,5 si
c'est moi je veux de ma place à
quelqu'un m'appelle à grand chose et
bien ça c'est pas mal mais c'est pas le
faire déjà c'est pas mal 503 déjà mes
hommages et je te fais benjamin castaldi
au top
[Applaudissements]
je te jure
allez m'aider series je suis je vais me
faire un petit coin pour des cas la
résonance athema je me sers de
l'éducation toutes les semaines comme
l'a fait pour ajuster haut niveau voilà
regardez il ya bien un petit coup de fil
à émeutes etc ou chm permal cyril ça
fait chier [ __ ] je ramenais bras
gauche voilà allez monsieur bah voilà sa
bien aimée c'est nul comme ça on va zy
rohff est ce que tu veux tu peux prendre
quelqu'un est ce que tu prends quelqu'un
pour tenter d'aller vite pas quelqu'un
qui serait la doublure officielle
photo dr est la doublure officielle je
vais prendre mon retard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont en plus moins costaud mais qui
peut être costaud mon avis raymond allez
[Applaudissements]
allez rêvons tous les bars dont tu
démarres way 140
leur père
ouais avec thales était gêné par j'ai
loupé j'ai loupé la série p je serais
beaucoup plus habituel même pas malin
toi bien de teko 50 fatal error
à mon avis c'est pas mal
à nous orienter dans les annales et
mokhtar et enfin dernier offre un
dernier
[Musique]
c'est beau c'est beau c'est bon quand
même
c'est bon quand même c'est beau quand
même bien 8,55 à la panse abouba attends
je pense à quelqu'un doit choisir
attentifs les emmène en finale et c'est
ça qui est bien
[Applaudissements]
tu te dois partir en se faisant battre
la même mois déjà au garde du corps m'a
dit t'as 810 a raté la balle et vénère
tu fais n'importe quoi
[Musique]
la psychopathe
[Rires]
émile énervé mais c'est quoi le record
bichon nice on le refera merci moi est
ce que j'aime c'est que mathieu rouy
nous a raconté sa vie de l'emmo grave
d'atteinte à toi sans rire oui j'ai de
la éducation là c'est vrai le loup